you ever have days where people expect
you to be something and you just don't
got it in you the thing about being
happy and basically an overall happy
person is that people still expect me to
not have a bad day so one of the things
i've learned about
my personality because i'm a people
pleaser as well i'm also a perfectionist
i i
i bet you understand a little bit of
what i'm talking about i do i do but
i've learned that you know
perfectionism is something wonderful to
strive to but it doesn't exist it's okay
now to say to your closest friends you
know what i'm not having the best day
today if it seems like i got up on the
wrong side of the bed it's because i did
it took a long time to learn that
because i didn't ever want anyone to
think there was ever a problem that
everything was okay when that's just not
life
that's not like there are problems and
crappy things happen and
you know
you you have to find the people that you
trust the most and communicate with them
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
what a pleasure to have on the show
today kristin chenoweth
and yes she is just as adorable as you
could imagine
i mean she has sparkly shirt on she has
a pillow that's red lipstick shaped and
colored she's an emmy and tony
award-winning singer she's an actress on
broadway as well as in movies she has a
holiday film coming out called christmas
song there's an album coming out called
for the girls and she has a show out
already on apple called shmigadoon
which what a funny concept it's about
this couple that gets lost and lands in
shmegadoon which is a living musical
and she plays like a really really funny
interesting mean character uh they can
sing
so well of course
uh but man the conversation
like we dropped in so fast we we got
right into the meat of
just being human and
the challenges and
you know growing up and how that affects
us and you know our environment the
friends that we have and what makes us
feel fulfilled and what doesn't and you
know the ways that we get filled up with
energy uh we also talked about of course
you know on the heels of that just being
a performer and
not having audiences and which is
something that she thrives on and is so
important and i get it like you make a
joke and if no one no one's there to
laugh do you know was it funny did it
hit and so
she uh she she kind of shares some
techniques she uses um to be able to
feel out whether or not something's
funny or not even without an audience
but
my gosh we just we just we just went
deep you know we talked about family we
talked about faith we talked about
spirituality um and then
you know i think all of us can relate to
trying so hard for something or not
getting out of a certain pattern that
might be unhealthy and
the ways that life
gets you to slow down enjoy the show
you're so glittery and pretty and alive
i was trying to fool you because i
actually have on no pants oh well i have
sweatpants on so i'm not sure what it's
worth to have sweatpants on or no pants
did you just say your boyfriend was
there so you know it probably makes
sense why you have no pants on let's
just say who he wears the pants in the
family
he literally has him he's like honey i'm
not gonna let you have any of your pants
i have them all the next boyfriend that
wants to wear my pants we're gonna have
to break up okay if you know what i'm
saying no no never again when they want
your shoes are they like your shoes or
pants i'm out right or they know what
your shoes are right isn't that another
thing when they know it's christian
louboutin
you know
no thank you let's go shopping not date
yeah yeah fun for that not the other
right
that's awesome
um well you you're you're glittering in
a way that i
imag like you're you're matching your
personality whenever i see you you're
always it just always i don't know you
don't just seem so happy you seem funny
and you just seem alive and you seem
like you just have so much electric
energy do you feel like that
um
you ever have days where people expect
you to be something and you just don't
got it in you and you just don't got it
in yet
so the the thing about being happy and
basically an overall happy person is
that people still expect me to
um not have a bad day so one of the
things i've learned about
my personality because i'm a people
pleaser as well
i'm also a perfectionist
i bet you understand a little bit of
what i'm talking about i do i do but
i've learned that you know
perfectionism is something wonderful to
strive to but it doesn't exist
and
you know
it's okay now to say to your closest
friends you know what i'm not having the
best day today if it seems like i got up
on the wrong side of bed it's because i
did
that way nothing is like
it took me a long time to learn that
because i didn't ever want anyone to
think there was ever a problem that
everything was okay when that's just not
life
that's not like there are problems and
crappy things happen and
you know
you you have to find the people that you
trust the most and communicate with them
yeah how was so how how many are you
your brothers and sisters yeah i have an
older brother he's four and a half years
older than me
and he is a chemical engineer not a
performer at all in fact he can't sing
and shouldn't ever
um
but i don't know what the heck he does
but we're really close he he he invents
technology i don't know but he's amazing
and he's been such a guiding force
as a big brother especially
of an age gap you know it was almost
five years so you want to look at it in
a way i was sort of like a single child
growing up from eighth grade on but that
was my big brother and he was almost
like a parent
and and honestly still is a little bit i
still want him to be proud of me i still
strive for him to go
that was kick ass you know or whatever
or that was really good when you did
because he's a man a few words and
um
and as you can tell i am not so
but we but yet we are very tight and
two people who shouldn't be close at all
on paper are
um yeah well i have a lot of friends
where
someone is just like me they're kind of
type a they're all in up for anything
tons of energy let's go let's work out
let's do the thing let's work out again
like i have people that are just like me
very straightforward call it like it is
a little brash and then i have
a lot i probably have even more friends
that are the opposite which they're the
ones that are super empathic they're
really sensitive and they're really
and they're just
they have all of the things that i don't
um
and and
and and lots that i do like you can't
get along with somebody that's not
similar and doesn't enjoy the same
things but from an emotional standpoint
and how they orient with people they're
opposite so it sounds like you and your
brother are maybe a little bit like that
you know i'm so glad that you brought
that up because i call them my lean in
friends
the friends that make you the friends
that make you think or their friends
that make you go why is she doing it
like that or the friends that you know
where they go to you and go girl what
are you doing thinking like you know
those are the friends and then to have
somebody that's kind of your mirror is
also nice too you can laugh and go
that's just like me i would do that i
would be the one to fall in the hole
that's me but
i don't really have a guideline my
friends are also different
yeah and
and they're also important and what else
i've learned as i've gone along you know
when you're growing up your best friend
forever is so-and-so your best friend
your best friend your best friend
i have family now at this point i have
chosen family and
i love
being able to say that not just as an
adopted child but i'm very close to my
my family but i am also extremely close
to my friends and i chose them
very carefully because i've been hurt in
the past who hasn't everybody has you
live and learn you know that saying of
friends or some are there for a lifetime
a season a reason
it's so true and now i don't i think
this may be a friend that this is just
what it is for this time and that's okay
i've gotten more okay with things as
i've aged
and from from a position of being a
people pleaser and wanting to take care
of whatever the relationship or them
that's probably a really huge phase for
you to be in that you can look at a
dynamic because the new version of you
is always going to cost you the old one
and sometimes that comes in the form of
relationships where you live your job
the things that you do
a lot of those things can fall by the
wayside and sometimes you look at it and
you just go it's part of growing is that
you know
you can't take everything with you and
that how how like what was the arc of
that and where did you like get stuck at
times where you're you look back now and
go man
you know i i needed to go through all
that but i probably hung on the for too
long
oh there's so many situations i'm i'm
i'm sure you understand first of all
just professionally speaking
i am going to work until i mean if
if they said rehearse i'm going to be
there before
you know that's just who i am i have the
thing memorized when i walk in it's just
who i i can't help
that being said what i've learned about
being that kind of person and this goes
into relationships of any kind
it's just because i work that way
doesn't mean that somebody else works
that way because i can get really
frustrated when i see somebody doing a
different process maybe
maybe it seems even lazy to me
but they still had the same
uh
ending i'm like how did that happen
because i did a b c d e f g
and he or she did
z
x
b and it seemed just fine
without
evolution or something or some might
call it enlightenment i call it
evolution because it's change it's it's
constantly evolving
and
when in my 20s
i left college and went to new york
and i had to do some real soul searching
not just musically and do you really
love this because if you don't love it
go do something else because this is
hard
and i really i came to realize this is
really what i want to do like i can't
see myself doing anything else and then
came to the realization of okay i'm from
the bible belt i'm a christian i have
certain beliefs how does that fit into
who you are in show business well i
decided when i was young and i think it
was
mature decision i don't know how i knew
this maybe god
i went okay
i'm gonna be me
and it's not gonna be pretty unhappy and
perfect for everybody
but i'm just gonna go ahead and be me
because
i can't i can't do anything
else and i think it's dolly parton that
says be you because everybody else taken
and it's the great piece of advice
she even says something to go further
she says
um find out who you are
and do it on purpose i'm like that's
what i said in my 20s i learned that and
i'm glad i learned that young
and was there an impetus or was this
just sort of being pushed in was it
having to decide if you loved acting and
if you loved singing and performing it
was a way of life annika like i'm from
oklahoma we get go to college we do a
sorority we get married we have a baby
we do our job we maybe have another baby
and then we age and we have a grand
judge you know that's what i'm supposed
to do i didn't do things like that
i did them a little out of order i'm
very much happy in a relationship but
i've always been like i'm never going to
get married i don't need a piece of
paper i i love jesus and god but i also
don't believe maybe that i'm right about
every single thing that other people's
views are also
valid you know you just wake up the kids
call it getting woke and and i think
faith has been so important in my career
but i'll even have friends that aren't
not not they're you know atheists and
they'll say will you just say a prayer
for me because because they know they
know i actually will and i go but you
have to believe it though i like to give
them crap you know but i i hope that my
friendship with people who are very
different from me
feeds them as much as their friendship
does with me and i've got
i've learned so much about judgment and
looking at things a different way since
moving to new york when i came here and
i was pretty open as a kid
to move to new york from oklahoma was a
big shock yeah i mean i didn't i lived
sort of in the south i mean you're we're
calling oklahoma the south right
because we're here but really we're in
the midwest right there's a way that
things go and and and sort of
traditional routes and you know to buck
the system
it almost feels like it's denying
the
validity or the or the or the i don't
know it's like denying the people
they're
saying they're wrong in a way
it's felt like that sometimes
and interestingly enough danica from
women
i'm like hey women you supposed to be on
my side you know right
but that's why i've looked at different
like for example dolly never became a
mother i talk about her a lot i love her
she didn't become they're just a choice
she made she said i have a lot of little
kids and i take care of well so do i so
i understood that that like made sense
to me you know carol burnett says i
can't imagine not having that had my
children sure so everybody you know
does it the way i was adopted what if i
change my mind and i decide
to adopt next year which you never know
with me um
there's so much love to go around in
this world i i mean it seems like i'm
curious about your relationship with
spirit as well as spirituality as well
as religion because you know from what i
can gather you don't necessarily believe
in all
facets and
structures and beliefs of religion um so
i'm curious about spirituality and where
that fits in
into your life um but you definitely
seem like someone that's like stays
pretty fluid and stays pretty um
open
and
and and fluid not only from a from a
from a perspective standpoint but also
even just from a physicality standpoint
physical standpoint where you're like um
you know even just not doing broadway
for too long like you know they want to
sign you up forever and you're like hi
you've got five minutes and then i'm
gone i love that word by the way and i
know it's and i'm i'm learning all the
the new terms like i know pivot is a
really big big word right now i'm using
it a lot so let me pivot back to the
subject one of the things i will say to
you danica about me and
this journey because really we're all on
it we're all on our own path and
everybody's dealing with their own crap
i don't mean to go i don't mean to go
down low i'm sorry but i'm going to say
this with faith
i've questioned my faith sometimes
because i've been sad and i've battled
depression before and i think it's
important to talk about because it's a
real thing i had fire across my face you
would run and say oh my gosh how can i
help you but mental health is just
because we can't see it doesn't mean
it's not there and
just having someone to talk to and say
is it okay that i question that or you
know i have that person in my life the
things that i've that i love to do which
i'm a puggy person i like to touch i'm a
big like lover i
i love to sing uh
you know all the things and that's how i
made my living too
it's like oh i'm being told no
no and that caused a real seven week of
like
well how are you gonna get back pulled
back up how are you gonna lift yourself
back up
and i you know i'm not a walking quote
but i have quotes that stick in my mind
well if you remember john edward the um
the uh politician his wife who's no
longer with us she passed away cancer
elizabeth
yeah i met or anything
but she has a quote that goes like this
it goes
she stood in the storm
and then when the wind did not uh blow
her way she adjusted her sails
and i think
if you could sum up my whole career
and ups and downs and because that's
what it is and life
it would
i've i'm really good at
adjusting myself
where do you get that from
i have two i have great mom and dad
um i saw my dad
make his business build it up lose it
and rebuild it i saw my mom work her
butt off to help him make that dream
come true i saw them work hard so that
my brother and i could go to soccer and
i could go to ballet and whatever else
thing i wanted to do and there were
times when when we didn't get to do that
i could have never could have never
afforded to go into new york danica and
sing a rock broadway show
so what we did is we went to tulsa and
when the show came through we
we'd go see that but that's why it's
important for me you know when we talk
about
kids in our life and being a mother
i have a camp in my hometown i brought a
broadway boot camp and it's hard i mean
people audition they get in it's grown
it's eight years we just had it wow
it's really it's grown we had seven
countries because we went virtual this
year and 33 states usually it's just
oklahoma but that to me is like okay you
passing it along helps you pull yourself
up
it's a selfish thing really
pulls yourself and it can pull you out
of sadness giving to others sounds
really
weird to say but when you give
to others it's actually
reverse psychology on us it works it
makes us feel better right
but you can't do it for that reason
though right
no no but no you've got to do it when
when the spirit takes you or like go
it's like when somebody asks you to say
a prayer and you go and i do it and
actually believe it
then
like there's some magic and believing i
mean there's magic sauce in that right
i couldn't listen you or i would not be
where we are today oh yeah if we didn't
believe
in something greater than ourselves
if we didn't believe in the power of
training and hard work if we didn't
believe that we were in a man's world
believe me i look at women i admire
i go
the things that we do have in common are
that
that work system that
don't i can't be stopped
yeah no and
it's hard to um teach that
either kids have it or they don't you
think you think you can't teach that i
don't think you can teach that i think
you can if kids kind of if they don't if
they want to do something they're going
to find their path they're going to find
their way they don't you can push all
day i'm sure you've seen kids be pushing
into your industry i've definitely seen
it i want to say to the parents they
don't want to do this
if you don't want to do this don't do it
it's hard but if you want to do it it's
the most amazing career ever yeah but
you have to believe i mean that was
definitely the story for me when i was
racing go-karts
and then
i went into cars and everything was
going fine and then all of a sudden i
was out of a ride
at like 19 years old 19 20 years old for
two years and i should be really in the
thick of it and really in the in the
craft
and i wasn't and i just but the whole
time i just call it blind faith that's
what i called it then and um but i just
believed that it was going to happen so
i'm so curious if if it's because
you know i don't know do we come in with
a mission is there something that we're
meant to do and so there's an innate
knowing or is it because i decided to
believe in it that it happened what do
you think i think it can be a combo
platter danica i think in my my case and
it sounds like your case there was
nothing i wanted to do more than be an
actor
a singer and dancer there was nothing
i would have i lived with four roommates
in bunk beds with a clapper okay i did
whatever i had to do to make it there
are certain kids that aren't going to
want to do that and i understand they
won't have a normal life they want to be
able to plan on a paycheck yeah well
they want medical you know they want all
these things yeah i was at vacation
bible school one year and
god literally said you're gonna be a
missionary and i was like oh not me you
got the wrong
four seasons hotel remember me god
anyway um
the missionary turns out to be
of a different it didn't look like what
i thought it was going to look like okay
describe the missionary what it what how
what is it
let's go to indonesia let's feed the
poor really feed the poor and sick that
we're supposed to do like let's go on a
journey let's spread the word of what
works for us makes us happy
being able to do that and i didn't think
it would be
talking about god or the lord or jesus
on broadway or maybe on a talk show or
maybe here today with you or i didn't
even think when i grew up that it was
all that
different
until i got to new york and i found out
that i was different
um
and i liked it i got the lesson early in
life too where
being different
once i finally allowed that because
there was a time that i kind of resisted
it where i didn't want to wear nail
polish heels like look too girly because
i mean i'm using my hands to describe
the car and i really need to reinforce
what's really obvious
um but as soon as i allowed myself to be
a woman in in different ways and and
just kind of go there it was like
through some photo shoots and stuff i
was like wow this doesn't actually take
away from anything that i'm doing it
makes me special and this is what's
unique and different about me and this
is like this is a cultural thing and and
and that people want to be like someone
else look like someone else do what
someone else does and and the truth of
it is is that they can never like
they'll they will literally never be the
person that they think is so great that
they want to be like um it's not
possible and the only thing you can do
is be second best and that's not gonna
get you there that's not gonna set it's
not gonna blaze a trail and so
the best thing you can do is figure out
what it is that's actually different
about you and run with it
i could not agree with you more that's
what i tell my kids all the time you're
saying it i wish they were all listening
you young broadway boot campers if
you're listening to this danica just
said what i say all the time man if you
if you can take that ball to the end
game and love it
like nobody gets input and if you can do
it with a weird run
do it you know do it i'm 411.
i have this unique speaking voice
you know i'm sure that in at times in my
career it has not served me but mostly
it has served me well because it's made
me different
and i've accepted that i sound like
betty boop and i've accepted that i
can't see over most counters and i've
accepted the things about me that we're
made fun of and that we fit better in
japan that's all there is to it when we
go please i love japan uh did you ever
resist it like did you have a point in
time where you resisted it that you you
know and what was that like because i
feel as though
you know
you know i'm all about trying harder and
pushing and there's definitely some of
that needed in life you've got to be
able to push through things to some
degree when it's difficult not
everything is so great but it's like
trying to recognize when you need to
pivot
and turn away from something go a
different direction let something go
and were there times where that you kind
of had to sort of get beat over the head
a little bit to get the message or not
when you cannot get a lesson and you're
so busy and you cannot hear the lesson
you cannot see the lesson that's what
sometimes it literally doesn't land on
your head and i was on it on a set with
a good wife doing maybe six episodes of
it and my day two the set big old set
piece thing landed on my head
fell in on my head and i was out of work
for six months what and i said yeah i
say this story because i had i had a
brain concussion and a six inch
cut and nose neck and ribs so what what
was hard for me was not to lay there
because on broadway we just get up and
we go
but with you know you break out a broken
leg you wrap it up and you get back out
there go but with a head injury
um i was in the middle of touring and
stuff they were not they weren't gonna
let me do that so i had that that and i
call it my own personal hell
of healing of being quiet
and listening when i
go go go go and i was like what's the
lesson what's the lesson what's the
lesson god's like i keep trying to tell
you like you've fallen in a hole which i
have backwards hurt your head another
another time like a light thing fell off
on me in the wing he's like i'm trying
to get your attention person because i
want you to rest so that you continue to
do what you love because i'm so used to
working through pain and injury i'm
sorry but that's a fact or sickness or
tire you know that's just what we do
and he just like stop
stop and smell the roses similarly i
remember it was a few years back
and i was like pushing hard i mean i was
still racing i was in nascar and
i was working out all the time working
out two a days you know i was killing it
and i mean i probably kind of knew that
i was pushing a little too hard within a
month i
spray my ankle and i even thought this
is a sign but i was like i'll just do
you know some upper body stuff and then
i was like
you know so doing that and then a couple
weeks later i'm doing a handstand in my
living room and i fell out of it a
little bit and when i landed my finger
went down and went
straight
i mean it's still bigger than this one
right here is still bigger than the
other one it's still it's been like four
years
and i so then now i have a sprained
finger and or like torn ligaments is
really good i'd rather have this sprain
than torn ligament oh yeah so it was
torn ligaments my ankle torn ligaments
in my finger and i'm like
finally the body was like i'm like okay
i get it no more time
like well i was thinking when you talk
about this story i'm thinking about um
our gymnast yeah simone who just had
so everybody was talking i was um
just walking off stage like my second
show back was feeling really good and
happy and i wanted to know how it went
for her
and my mom called me and she said the
most beautiful thing happened with her
i said she won everything she beat her
own time blah blah blah blah she said no
none of that
i have vertigo i have an inner ear
problem and so i'm very conscious when
someone can't land something or they
seem off i'm very aware that because she
said i'm spinning she kept saying i'm
spinning and i can't land i don't know
what she has and i'm not
i have no idea but what she did
in a matter of a few hours
by showing her team and the world what
kind of sports woman she is to me was
more important than anything she could
have beat or won her time so her lesson
was actually a lesson for us
to watch someone with such grace
say i can't do it i can't do it but my
team can and i'm going to be there for
them and that's that's probably why i
like doing broadway and
why i like a fam
familial feel
um
i imagine in your sport it's fun but it
could be maybe a little lonely i think
that about track stars you know you're
only competing with yourself well yeah i
am too because if they want me for a
part they certainly don't want someone
else if they want someone else they
certainly don't want me but what i have
learned is like really chris life's
short life is so short and the sweating
the small stuff is just
not worth it
yeah
well not only did you get hit over the
head but then everyone got hit over the
head
with covid last year so
turn that frown upside down
yeah exactly what i was just talking
about
um
uh
you want to tell me about that how'd
that go
sure
let's see other than
these becoming my new favorite treat
i was like when somebody everybody
developed a love for something like i
probably drank too much wine you know a
little bit for a while you know i think
this is another time
i say have an extra glass okay
extra glass um
see my little lovely little record back
there we were getting ready to i'd done
a run on broadway at the concert of this
album called for the girls i was really
proud of it still now
but the coven was just hitting
and so the target after two months got
cancelled which that's how i sell
and
i was
pretty bummed out about it and
it was my mother who said
are you sad that you're not going to
sell as many records as you normally
would are you are you are are you happy
that it lives on
and i love that's called the juni
channel sideswipe she gives you a choice
so that if you say the negative one then
you're just definitely a debbie downer
right
like you can't make the wrong choice
kristen i said well i'm happy it lives
on obviously but you know
so it lives on kristin you know how many
people would give anything for a record
deal it lives on stop
so i've had women in my life like that
well because they're both true i mean
even if you would have toured it still
lives on so but she made you focus on
the positive
yes and she's like you you right now
everybody i was like but i have dates
and i have gigs and she's like
and so does everybody you're not special
and then the first seven weeks
we were josh josh was to play at
birdland he's a guitarist and i was
going to play a philadelphia orchestra
and that we caught up here i had two
weeks of a tour after the broadway run
caught up here and i was like are they
going to call this thing because i'm
watching philadelphia come up with cases
after seven weeks i live across from the
hospital i just here in new york and i i
also live in la and i asked josh to um
take a risk with me i said would you
would you
would you get on a plane right now and
go to l.a with me because my spirit
because what we saw
here across the street was so hard
difficult
i just i i couldn't do it i admit it i
thought i thought it was a tough girl
you know
i was there during 9 11. you know i'm a
new yorker but i just
we got our groceries in the middle of
the night so we saw some things you know
that the hospitals have to do during the
night and i just became uber needing to
leave we got to la and at least i could
walk around in my
you know remember in new york we we got
it we got hit hard we got hit
hard new york seemed like a i mean it
it's always a concrete jungle but now
it's like it's like a concrete prison
yeah and as a new yorker you know that
breaks my heart yeah
and i want broadway to come back but i
want it only if it's safe
yeah you know we're all going through
the same thing your sport you know
that's why i think annika and i love
your take on this i'm a huge basketball
nut
and i i really like um
nba but i watch college when when it's
on
and have you noticed that a lot of these
teams that were projected to win
everything
didn't and the ones who weren't
projecting or even on the list won
everything or went so far that nobody
could believe and i think it's because
there's no audience there's no audience
so
if you're the kind of energy of the
audience
and people don't understand that that
feeds me okay and i know it feeds you oh
wow and that's just nobody there
yeah that has to get hard to
get into the mode and like feel a
purpose and not just feel like it's
rehearsal in some way and you know
because there's a difference between you
know even when i rehearse something
versus when it's time it's like don't
worry i'll click it up a couple of
notches yes you know but i did do a lot
of and i know that you understand this
now i'm a little late to the party but i
i've done so much zooming
i've done
i've i've sold a tv show by zoom i've
done lots of press by zoom i was in
canada doing a tv show and i did all my
meetings by zoom over there oh i did a
movie in my closet the witches an hbo
animated i did a movie in my closet oh
yeah i just i just adjusted i adjusted
my sails i think you're an extrovert
probably
i'm both it's
because
the fact that you know because i get
energy from being alone i can be with
people and specific kinds of people i
don't lose energy and it's kind of a
little invigorating especially if it's a
good deep conversation and you know i
don't do well with surface conversation
i don't do well with
a lot of people
in general like it's a it's an it's an
effort to kind of make the small talk
and keep it going um but i want to
present my best self the fact that
there's no audience i mean i get that
and then you know not being around
people are you so you say you're both
i'm both in in but i'm different than
how you are
i like to have my alone time to rest
you're not even reading about rehab or
like a regeneration or a generation yes
and without that
i can get get a little
off
course
and um
in canada i was i was going to say this
we were shooting the show called
schmegadoon it is musical musical
and um i had an 18-page song and and the
director shot it in once one take i know
you know
i know you know
i know you know because you've worked in
film and you understand
so i had 14 days of quarantine so guess
what it doesn't mix well with kristin
chenoweth quarantine
um i hated it
i i watched 90 day fiance and i learned
that song that's all i did and by day
eight i was a little bit like
and i just
immersed myself in it and then once i
finally got out
of quarantine and i could be around
people then i was afraid to
what it's like that even on set i was
like well because this was pre-vaccine
and i thought we were at the height of
covet and here i am on a set i got i got
weird so then i go home at night and be
weird and like weird on set be weird and
alan kevin was in the show and he's
we're very very close he said why are
you being so weird i said i know right
i'm being weird you're out of quarantine
we're safe we're in our pods you've said
you're wearing a cone like you've been
spayed or neutered
quit being weird i'm like you're right
i'm sorry but it has sucked okay it just
sucked it sucked for all my all the
broadway community
it is we we are managing to do tv and
film and i've been lucky to work that
way and make a living that way but i
mean i've friends moving in droves out
of town of new york because you know
rent job life
i think that's happening in a lot of big
cities i mean i live in scottsdale and
oh we love scottsdale never been better
like everybody's coming from california
and
i mean it's like you know there's
there's some people maybe that are over
the city and then maybe it has to do
with just
you know something to do with the city
and perhaps they don't agree with it all
perhaps it's just about the fact that
they know that they can just zoom their
way to work and that they don't have to
actually be in an office anymore so
where do you want to live well i don't
want to live in this
730 square foot apartment in new york
i'd like to have a yard you know maybe a
dog
yeah
yeah there's a lot of people do that
danica and it's also happening in
california because i live there as well
so much so that
that
you also act so you know that california
a lot of things aren't shooting there
unless it's a talk show
most things are shot in canada atlanta
soon to be oklahoma thank goodness
not in our country so and so i did a
movie in north carolina
but i'm
getting to the point where i and i've
loved canada over the years i've been
there many times and shot many many many
some of my favorite work but i'd like
for our country to to get some of the
tax breaks and and get some of the
breaks that they're getting
you know through us and they're our
friends no doubt about it but i just
wish i wish
that you know in my
industry so i've decided to move from
from california because i don't really
work there as much right right um and
i'm moving to nashville that's a great
city i mean that's a lot of fun there
i'm planning on having a great time do
you feel like you're going home in a way
being a success
you said that south western midwest girl
do you feel like you're kind of going
home
yes i do feel like i'm going home when i
was 18 i worked at opryland it no longer
exists it's gone away but i
left kicking and screaming going to ocu
my dad said you're going to college i
said no i want to sit work and operate
them for the rest of my life and he said
no you have to go to school and i'm so
glad he did what he did but nashville
has always been the place where i
thought
i would want to be
i'm a new yorker
through and through but it's music city
there too
so they understand but it's not um
sometimes i think i'll be interested to
get your take on this and we're both in
show business so we know that there's
certain ways that people want us to look
sometimes and look
you're seeing that real this is the real
hair this is the real i did my best
danica but you know
i'm used to having hair makeup done i
did my best it was adorable you're my
best
well you are too but you know you get to
the point where you get
kind of spoiled
with getting your hair and makeup done
and now i've got to get in front of the
light now i'm going to be a tech person
and
i'm 53 i can barely do social media just
give me a freaking break everybody like
i'm
i'm with you yeah i'm trying but you're
not liking me so i'm still trying to get
there and i'm
i'm learning you know pivot he she they
i'm getting it i'm getting it the sales
turn it
re-route the
jib and this thing is
we love a jib so was it so fun to be
back on set so schmegadoon you said it
so now i know how to say the word what a
fun show and i think too
like
i mean what the best of both worlds i'm
curious
it's clear you love broadway the most
right above movies i love stage if i'm
on a concert or in a role i just like be
on stage stage with with with an
audience right yeah is there an audience
for schwein
well yeah and
the premises and this is what makes me
laugh so hard because my brother can't
stand music theater or opera
pearl clutch me
so i'm like
how do we get people to watch this well
there's a character that keegan michael
key plays he's the guy that hates
musicals so a couple wants to revitalize
their relationship and they go on a trip
they get lost and they get stuck
in a musical
and that's where i live my brother's
hell it's your brother's hell is hell
and my heaven yeah
when someone said to him the other day
about the show
how how much they don't it was a german
a german a lady from germany said i
don't really like musical theater
and so we've never really had an
interview before but
i've liked you and other things i didn't
even know you could sing
oh and so she goes but i found myself
cracking up at schneiderdoon and
i thought well then we're doing what we
set out to do which is make people laugh
not at us just at the situation and i
really like i love the concept of the
show and i'm curious of your thoughts on
a
much more sort of deep esoteric level
but this couple
can't leave schmegadoon and this living
musical
until they find true love
right right and but they're supposed to
be in love right
right because they come as a couple so
okay like unpack that for me how is that
playing out and then what are your i
mean i'm curious just you know i want to
talk about true love too oh me too i
love that subject um love love i think
what's
making what's ringing true is that
when musical theater is done poorly
um
we should be made fun of we should but
when it's done at its highest level then
it's it's actually the hardest milia of
the tv broadway all the it's the hardest
thing now we're doing it on film okay so
there's there's a line that i've got to
walk with this crazy banana character
that i've got to walk but for film not
for theater
and it's a comedy
so kristin how are you going to do that
and maybe this isn't even your question
but for any young artists listening
and watching
what i did what i do when there's no
audience which is a lot of times
i look at camera a and if they're
cracking up
then i know it's funny
that's right you can't because they
can't hold it back i get it right you're
looking to any context like you can be
doing an interview and sit there and and
people aren't supposed to make noise but
you can kind of hear a
you know you can hear like a little
giggle or something yeah that's where a
live audience can really like perpetuate
the energy and jack it up more and more
because they're cracking up you're
feeling the flow like you're the right
things are building at the right times
because there's there's there's
immediate feedback but when you've got
nobody
yeah that makes perfect sense look at
the cameraman yeah i was like jim was
that funny or no and barry sanchez would
you quit asking jim i'm the director
well i just want to know is it reading
and you know i'm still that girl i still
want to be
true to the character true to myself
true to the peace
um and i play a very unlovely person in
the in the show very unlovely but very
fun very very fun and he seems like a
really um
i mean could she be some kind of
ulterior
like like personality
how do you tap into her well i i went
back in time dove cameron who's played
my daughter twice before and our and i
are very close she's placed the young
sort of hot you know farmer's daughter
in the show
and i was like why is mildred what's
made mildred so mean nasty leads with
anger
even hate and hurt insecurity what's
made her all these things
so my job as an actor is to
one day we were staying in rehearsal i
was watching dove and she was so the
character and i was cracking up at her i
said ah
mildred used to be her
but through some of the things that i
can't mention in the show through time
and things that have happened in
mildred's life she's become angry
and mean and she's lost her joy she's
allowed this life and other people to
take her joy and that's the only way i
have to look at characters like that
that way or i would have trouble playing
them because they're so unlovely but
they're also a lot of fun you know i had
i had the joker lips i really wanted her
to be a maniacal at some point
drive to this episode five which this
one take number thing
and i really wanted like of course it
was really tight made me really
uncomfortable
i had that too tight mildred pierce hair
and just everything was
super crisp
and perfect and she was just
unhappy
and
it was fun to play had a great day that
dichotomy of perfection and then
misery i just missed just miserable i
think it's beautiful that you were able
like that you to get in to find the
character
you actually look for the good to see
to see the contrast
and
do you not
do you think this isn't just the case
for everyone
and while you know you're forced to do
it on set because you're getting into a
role but this is so much harder to do in
real life where we've got someone
projecting on to us and you've got a
mildred in this you know in regular life
and you're you know you just you can you
just it's like you don't want to deal
with it and it gets so hard in those
moments to see
the little kid that was bebopping around
at seven that things happened to them
and the thing is is that everybody's
dealing with [ __ ] like everybody's every
mama everybody
everybody and i don't know about you but
hasn't this time really made you look
like what's really the problem oh my god
you i'm totally
it
me too um my mom trauma my dad trauma i
thought it was the dad trauma that was
the problem turned out there's mom
trauma too like of course
of course thank god for counselors thank
god for
quiet thank god for some reflection
thank god for
you know the
the the things that have to hit you over
the head before you're like thrust into
situations but man if we could only have
that kind of attitude and maybe you do
all the time i you should i'm curious
i have troubles too
so
my mom said
are you sad that you're not gonna make
as much are you are you you know i was
like oh she's right she's doing that
thing again sniper from the side i call
it she's right it's a way to train your
brain too like
i i don't love the expression fake it
till you make it but there is some point
to it especially in during a pandemic
like when you walk outside and you see
sadness and you just see loneliness and
you want to help and whatever
or you don't really want to go out
because you're depressed either way i've
noticed
that in my past growing up people said
to me as a child you smile a lot it
makes people feel good so i always
thought well that'll be that's something
i do naturally so that'll be easy
because i like to can't help it
but i've noticed that people smiling at
me when i'm walking down the street just
like
like we see each other
we know we've been through hell we're
still in it
and a smile to somebody even if you
don't get the reaction back that even if
you don't get him to smile back you
never know how that will touch people i
had a woman just not long ago just
randomly
smile at me as i was walking by hi
that's hi and i thought i wonder if she
knows how badly i needed that smile
so you know
it's it's an interesting time to be
alive danica and i think about all the
kids graduating from college with their
dreams and they still got their super
suitcases packed full of their clothes
and where are they gonna go
so we'll we'll just continue to unpack
this for years
but i guess the main thing is we're
alive
and i do see a light at the end of the
tunnel i see a light
and there is so that means hope yeah
well we don't you know what i'm hearing
is that
you know the saying that we don't see
things as they are we see things as we
are
and so
you see the smile because you give the
smile like you see it you know that
sometimes you've smiled at people when
maybe you weren't even feeling it
sometimes because it's just it's your
it's your gift you know
this is your this is your magic you
sprinkle on
human existence and so
you could see that amongst i'm sure tons
of other things but it's only in the
breaking open into the depression
and into getting hit over the head
literally
that you then kind of are able to then
empathize with that person who's the
mildred who you're like oh she used to
be joyful and happy and then something
happened but it's it's not until you can
kind of feel it so again it's not we
don't see things as they are we see
things as we are and it's in the
breaking open that we can create so much
more compassion and i think that's hap i
do think that there's such a golden
opportunity to expand as humans into
this like much bigger love but much
wider it's just wider
everything you said plus times 10
because we don't have compassion
not only will our country not move
forward we won't you know we're talking
about
enlightenment evolution things like that
i like that word
if we don't have compassion at the end
of it that's that then then we have
nothing
and um it's very easy to look around and
why me why me why me why this why this
why this and you know we were talking
about true love earlier and
how i was supposed to do this certain
thing you know and
it wasn't until this hideous moment
and i i had met um my my current
boyfriend
before but kobe really
bonded us and i think it either bonded
people
or it separated people
yeah you're right
you're right i mean like absolutely i
mean it should speak volumes about
relationships the things that survived
that you were immersed there was no more
hiding it was all shadows coming out it
was all insecurities the triggers and
projections are just flying like birds
in the sky constantly
yes it's a really trying time but you
know
not only whether you found deeper love
or whether you were broken and found a
breaking open to feel the pain to
appreciate and see the love too like
it's all working and i think that no
it's like it's almost like when when
there's a cause happening and it goes so
far one direction it's like there has to
be some sort of a stretching before it
kind of finds its middle ground and
there's a lot of stretching going on it
is very well said very well said and a
lot of stretching that needed to happen
and then
also so that you know when we're talking
about being aware
of
our surroundings being aware of others
being aware that our words hurt being
aware that just because we don't think
it's offensive they shouldn't
you know it's really an interesting and
i
it's a silly thing but i i
i'm from oklahoma and you know some of
my relatives hunt okay they do and
i've get
gotten in trouble before for saying i'm
gonna kill two birds with one stone by
peta and it doesn't matter i'm happy to
talk about these things by the way it's
important
you have to think about that yes the
thing
it's a saying but you know there's a lot
of sayings that i've i've learned now
that you know what kristin you don't
need to say that that's actually
like
that's not even you don't even need to
say that there's a bunch of things that
have disappeared from our lexicon in the
last good few years because of
other implications and it's good it's
good it's good and
i don't know how you feel but
but the black ice matter movement came
um when i
went back to la it kind of erupted right
then yep um and it was very difficult to
continue to watch george floyd what
happened to him and he and to his family
that this moment needed needed to happen
and all the stretching
and i need to stretch too so this time
out has been
the hardest thing i've ever done and the
most required thing i didn't know i
needed
i have a tendency to go go go that i
don't even live in the moment sometimes
what are we supposed to do one number
one thing
oprah says it live in the moment god
says
let me take you on i'll be you're gonna
be okay but i've i'm i'm learning that
and i'm 53 and i'm getting there
i
feel you i have the same problem i like
to go go go
um i don't mind being like i didn't kill
me to be in quarantine i like the alone
i love certain aspects of it but i do
have a hard time slowing down too what
is it
you know if we can't find the lessons in
these things it gets you know then
there's
it's just a little less
useful so yes what are the lessons other
than purely slowing down i'm like more
specific what do you realize that you
need in your life the things that you
like to do where you want to be you're
moving so maybe that's a part of it but
what are the things that you go
at once the dust settled the things left
are these
my mom and dad my boyfriend my closest
friends my dog like i'm looking around
now as you ask the question like you
don't really need that racket clothes
yeah don't really need that hat don't
need
i mean i don't want my steinway to go
away but
i couldn't imagine
there's so many things i've realized
that i don't need i like to dress up and
be cute and i like to be all girly and i
like clothes and all that stuff and it's
been hard like
i wanted to just go somewhere to the
mall we go to lunch something but as as
long as
this goes
vera wang to the to the grocery store
yes okay
but even like my cute sweats no i wore
winnie the pooh onesie the whole
pandemic like with food on it from three
days ago like what's the matter kristen
shower
and for everybody listening that i went
through this feeling too i want you to
know you were not alone like when i
smelt my own breath
in my mask when i smell my own breath i
nearly pass it out from my own breath
ladies and gentlemen
and you know what i'm talking about no
one's talking about mass breath no one
is
because it's masked
one of the only good things about the
mask is that you don't have to worry
about your breath yeah until you remove
it and you go oh we're good and you
remove and then you start talking you go
is that me or someone else's foot
realize oh crap it's your breath
yeah so listerine has become very
important to me okay nice nice
but um what uh did you have any emerging
sort of like hobbies or things that you
ended up realizing that you just
freaking down with and you want to keep
doing i'm embarrassed but do you mind if
i go get something yeah go for it i love
it show and tell okay
so i have
no obsession i'm i it's a problem
it's um coloring
coloring books yes now this is my best
one i think hang on
i'm obsessed i do it at night to bring
down my brain you know from the day
yeah oh colors that's stunning all those
colors of green yeah and then here's the
real key you've got to have a electric
pencil sharpener organic or don't waste
your time because me and you are not the
type to do this we're not doing that we
have to go like that i don't know i i
like the extra workout you know it's
like
you know what it might be you might be
oh
my god that's the deluxe
coloring set
that's probably a hundred and fifty
different colors at least no wonder why
you were able to get so many shades of
green you should see
in something
wow i work really hard at these danica
uh they take a lot of time and a lot of
sharpening
by the way my poor boyfriend is like i'm
i can't sleep i'm an insomniac i don't
know how you're dealing with maybe you
don't have that problem but i said it's
a problem and i color if i wake back up
i'll color but then the pencil sharpener
noise
you know true love
my mouth guard i'm like sorry honey i
mean
as you're like sorry i'm excited to just
get the sharpeners going
oh where's my finger yeah we're about
there
that's adorable well i don't think
that's a bad and and so to me that's
like some people develop maybe
a meditation sort of like routine
maybe someone picked up gardening maybe
someone
i don't know started cooking who knows
but i should have done that anything
that gets the brain to
slow down and go from
sympathetic to parasympathetic like
that's or the other way around i always
forget which way it goes but to slow
down
is such a great such a great thing
well i mean i want to ask you something
because
believe it or not
when you were racing
it wasn't
all that much different than what
what i do okay i get put in a
a capsule basically on stage and i go
from eight to eleven and i don't stop
and then coming home at night and if i'm
doing concert work it's me you know and
i it's the night time i'm a night owl
already but then i get switched over to
a film
and you know it's like 5 30 a.m miss
jenna with i'm like
please don't do that to me please don't
do that to me because i'm a night owl i
stay up all night long and i really
struggle with it how did you come down
when you were racing or how do you end
just life because you know we go off
adrenaline that's clear yeah we're
adrenaline junkies for sure i mean look
what we do for a living you're also an
actor look what you're doing now you're
doing a podcast because oh let's add one
more thing
because you're that amazing
seriously there's definitely a countdown
period yeah there's a come down period
and i think that you know you know the
nature of your business is is not quite
as dramatic moat's very similar as like
a chef um same thing like those night
hours where there's got to be like a
come down because you're in
high beta mode
neurologically yes you
stay on and stay focused and so to get
out of that brainwave state and get
lower and into sort of like alpha before
you can get into like delta and theta
when you're sleeping like that's a
process that takes a while to get down
there so
for me i i mean i think it always took a
couple hours
uh-huh and then i was fine to sleep i'm
fortunate i i just i did an interview
and i we we were talking about sleep in
the interview and it was with david
asprey who's a um
yeah and so i said that i wake up
um and i'm almost never tired in the
morning and he's like okay almost
everybody listening hates you um because
that's not how people feel and we're
jealous and we're happy for you oh
thanks yeah um but i
i definitely
am
uh i go with the sun so
i
i once the sun comes up i'm up so
you know
it's crazy and to stay up all night and
then sleep in the daylight is not
necessarily the way the body's meant to
work
but that has caused me problems but it's
your work and so even if you if you
finish at 11 by time you get home it's
midnight maybe you probably want to eat
something which is another sort of like
sleep disrupter it is then all of a
sudden
yeah you probably don't want to eat
before the show too much because you got
to sing and you got all these things
going on so you know of course it's to
put on and then you know and then and
then you've got a couple of hours of
like come down from the energy and then
you've got
digestion and all these other things
happening it's
it's just i mean it's lifestyle and so
you know it's
how do you do it i mean there's pro you
probably have to i would think like
finding a cave basically sort of setting
where it's like got to be pitch black
you can't slide in
maybe even i
yes yeah maybe really cold it should be
really really cold in there so hertz
frequencies are
so there's like a lot of conspiracies
around the frequency in which we tune
music to which this will kind of maybe
strike a chord with you
so 432 is a natural natural frequency
and 440 was an implemented frequency for
music and it's a little less natural to
the body so you can look on like you can
go on youtube and just search hertz
frequencies and they'll be anywhere from
20 minutes that you can listen for a
meditation if you want to 10 hours worth
so i just play it and then i leave it
next to the bed and i listen to whatever
frequency i want so sometimes i listen
to
528 or 432 which are kind of more of
like
i think earth that resonates at a 528
frequency 432 they're very healing then
you can get into the lower frequencies
which are more bodily healing so and
then you can get into higher frequencies
that are more about uh sort of astral
projecting and more of sort of uh
connecting with the connecting with
spirit connecting with the astral plane
you know what you should try please tell
me you should try putting it putting in
putting on a headphones if you have a
cord that's great because then you don't
have the emfs from uh wireless
um put on headphones and play a hertz
frequency while you color and see how
you feel with that because i bet you'll
just go
are you serious
i've never even heard of this before
like i'm not a beginning like this i'm
trying this
oh i i and there's also you know there's
also products that work great i i
invested into a company and promote this
product called it's beam it's is the
name of the company and they have a
sleep product called dream and it has no
cbd
you've had drink it has magnesium
alkinene melatonin and you've got about
a 20-minute window so if you played that
music colored and took your dream which
is basically just like a hot chocolate
and you drink it in 20 minutes you
should feel pretty damn tired
i bet
i'm so doing this i have not tried this
all in together i've not done them i've
done different sound apps and things but
i haven't done what you're talking about
but but anything yeah like you know
we're talking about rewiring the brain i
think the same goes with like depression
and like love and all the emotions we
have and
i love the reason i love sleeping is
because i am
um
sort of an empath
and uh that's when i've had several
visitations from people that i love that
are no longer here so that's
when i get in my dream i'm really
getting good sleep and i love it when i
get a business oh
yeah so you'll probably totally dig on
some of those higher frequencies the
like
nine nine and a thousand that's like 963
and something you you that'll connect
you more with those frequencies those
higher chakra frequencies in the astral
um that's interesting so
you operate in the dream state then
quite a bit do you remember your dreams
um
usually i do i write them down
quickly
so that they don't leave me but
when a big moment happens i don't forget
i i mean i can still like i can remember
when my aunt came to visit me and she
was laughing
she didn't say anything to me but she
was laughing she said she had such a
unique laugh
and she had had brain breast cancer then
brain cancer and passed away and
she was the youngest and healthiest of
six girls eight organic top spin all the
all the things that you think how did
this happen
but she was laughing in my dream
laughing and
in my dream i go and i go are you
laughing at me and she's no i'm no i'm
trying to tell you to laugh because it's
just all so silly don't be sad
now she didn't speak it but that's what
her meaning was to me and i thought oh
she's telling me not to be sad about her
it's also good did that make you look at
death different after having that
experience because when we have those
visceral but
out-of-body experiences there's
something that shifts internally that
doesn't doesn't go back i feel like you
you you're changed forever change
forever when that thing hit me in the
head
i was knocked out i woke up in bellevue
and
there was no shining light there was
just me out and then
coming too
and
he got me to thinking about a lot of
things i said mom i didn't see the
shining light i didn't you know she's
like well you aren't mid
you gotta you get a brain injury which
is serious but you aren't dead so
and chosen by the way who are you
hearing this from you know who's coming
back and telling you there'll be a big
beam of light you know none of us knows
what it's going to be live none of us
knows i just know that i so totally
believe that we are all spirits in these
bodies right and we get to walk around
this fantastic earth which is one of a
billion thousand
zillion
planets
and
we're here in the now and
i'm so grateful for it
i've had a lot of loss this year and i'm
really grateful for
all the hardship
because it just really makes you
appreciate
the good things if you
were to
be at the end of your life
um
well human life
because you probably also believe that
we you know we don't die even the bible
says that oh you don't die go on so
but if we're just you know spirits
having a human experience um what will
you hope that you
will have done
in this human experience this cycle of
being a human
and what will you want to be remembered
for
i hope that people will remember me as a
person who um
was
always wanted to be on a team and just
wanted to be a team player
and that's in life and that's on stage
and that's if i'm the
headliner or if i'm not doesn't matter i
like
like my background singers they're not
background singers they're singers
that join me on stage they're artists
um i hope they remember that about me
and i hope
that i've left an impression on
some of our younger generation
about the craft and art of a voice
and dance and
how arts can change lives
and so i hope that
a child somebody
in my lifetime says kristen
you know i have had kids say to me
before you know i'm in it because i saw
you do abc but i really this boot camp
thing
we had two kids get signed by big and
that's not actually what i wanted but
i'm really happy that there's enough
there's so many kids out there that want
to do
what i do what i do but
another reason that the movement is so
important what you were saying
especially
when you hit it
girls women
everywhere went if she can do it
if she can do it and that's what you
know i'm sure you realize that now but i
wonder i've wondered about you in the
past like this she realized that she
just gave a whole generation of women
going she can do is like the girl
playing football the other day i was
happy to see it you know go you go crawl
you just go now me i'll be up now
someone but you just go right on ahead
but i have i've just that's what i hope
those are the two things i hope
in life
are there some things left on the list
that you know that you are there's some
i'm sure there's things left on the list
but are there some things and that was
beautiful by the way i mean that is such
a that is such an empathic
um hope for life i mean i can feel the
empath in you that wants like
you want you you want them to feel what
you've felt and you want to feel what
you want you want to feel them because
the joy that you get doing it you want
to see it in them and you want them to
experience it for themselves and that is
like such an empathic thing to say
because there's just a mirroring
happening that you just want them to be
in such joy and love something so much
and connect
and that's really beautiful
um what about experiences for yourself
that you um that you would like to
uh
do
between now and the end of this meat
suit
well i'm sure my boyfriend would like
for me to say that i'm gonna learn how
to cook um
i'll teach you
would you yeah
okay i'll
i will take you up on that because i'm
the worst
oh
worse you almost can't screw it up
really yeah it's true as long as you get
good at just tasting food as you go you
go oh it just needs more salt oh it just
needs more sugar oh it just needs more
that so you just start slow adding
things and then all of a sudden you're
like oh and then all of a sudden you're
like i'm gonna get into flavor
complexity and i'm going to get into
texture differences and all of a sudden
you're like look what i came up with and
you can't screw it up i really can't i
mean you can burn something to a char
sure
but i still like a little char like if i
burn something i'm like [ __ ] sorry guys
i burn it a little bit secretly i'm like
i'll eat it and most people are like i
love charred food too
i like a snake steak a steak well done
is there anywhere you want to go or any
anything that you know
i don't know have 10 dogs or you know
machu picchu or
let me explain something to you if i
went to any sort of mountain
whether it's a hill
or just one in my neighborhood i'd never
make it over the top i'm so out of shape
um
i've always i've i've been lucky enough
to be all over the world
but i have never been to israel or um
jerusalem and i would really like to go
there before
i pass away i would like to see
all the things i've read about my whole
life i'd like to see the wailing wall i
would like to see
bethlehem i would like to see yeah
i just want to go
um if your boyfriend's listening
standing behind the camera now you know
what to do now now you know it's a book
yeah
what oh
he said you can cook an egg muffin
you can or can't cook an egg muffin i
can that's the one thing i can do and he
loves them that's a gem i mean that's
that's breakfast or lunch or dinner what
do we think eggs are the best
i know cookies i can make those out of a
bag
popping hearts i'm great at those oh
wait i draw the line there if you only
have to push down on the button then
it's not
that's not that's not we're gonna we're
that often is a real accomplishment
well i hope you do all those things i
have actually no doubt that you will
especially now that your boyfriend knows
what to plan
but uh as far as you know as far as the
cooking goes
i'd be happy to help but at the end of
the day
you're pretty great you've accomplished
so much you've inspired so many and
you're such a doll and if you never
learned how to cook in your life
job well done
thank you sweetheart
thank you for making me feel that good
man so you're in north carolina right
i'm not i lived in north carolina for
about five years but i love you at
arizona scottsdale i play there all the
time i love arizona do you like it i
love it yeah yeah i've been here on and
off since 2004 so okay i really like it
out here north carolina was nice too but
um and nashville's cool i've been there
a bunch of times but i've never lived
there no you want to if you want to come
visit
in the meantime enjoy getting back on
the road and audiences and all the good
all the things
thank you danica and same back at you
sis stay safe thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button